what you're looking at depending on who
you ask is either a revolution for the
internet and countless Industries as we
know it like in all seriousness I
compare it to the internet or the
greatest Ponzi scheme in human history
that whole thing is a promise that you
can get rich
for free
accused of being all of these things is
the world of cryptocurrencies or the
other labels associated with it nfts
blockchains web 3.0 from the bizarre
onslaught of celebrity promotions and
endorsements I got an ape Too part of
the same Community we're both apes to
the eye watering numbers and headlines
digital artist people the final bid 69
million dollars oh my God to the
grandiose claims about its potential
it's the biggest technology that has
ever happened in the
I once described the world of
cryptocurrencies as a story and I did
that in hopeful optimistic tones and now
now I don't think is the story that I
initially thought it was they only make
money because some other sucker lost
more have fun staying poor it amazes me
that anybody is buying into this they
are decentralized ponji's teams the only
thing that you have to show is Ponzi
schemes it's all [ __ ]
oh
for me and many others
it began here what you're looking at is
a piece of artwork by a digital artist
called Michael Joseph winkelmann
otherwise known as people on February
the 25th of 2021 this artwork was put on
auction bidding started at a hundred
dollars
it eventually sold for 69.3 million
dollars
making it one of the biggest sales in
digital art history that's what I do
feel
Super Lucky what happened afterwards
foreign
[Music]
Halls that it doesn't exist in physical
form it is only available digitally it's
the first nft ever sold at auction
non-fungible token nft nfts are
non-fungible token explain nfts to
people that don't know what you're
talking about because I don't know what
you're talking about it was like
suddenly the term nft was just
everywhere Jack Dorsey co-founder of
Twitter sells a picture of his first
ever tweet as an nft Jack Dorsey
auctioning his first tweet as digital
art 2.9 Million Dollars even popular
internet memes were selling as this nft
thing Nyan Cat 590 000 Charlie bit my
finger 760 999 dollars disaster girl
five hundred thousand dollars Doge 4
million dollars overly attached
girlfriend 411 000 Bad Luck Brian 36 000
Scumbag Steve 57 000 you had singer
songwriter Grime say killing six million
dollars worth of digital art as nfts
people were changing their profile
pictures on social media to nfts that
they had purchased it was like flexing
an expensive car or a watch and then
suddenly all these big celebrities and
artists and influences were also
replacing their profile pictures with
nfts and announcing their own purchases
of nfts and the Apes the Apes were were
part of this bigger project of nfts
called board ape Yacht Club I mean you
had Snoop Dogg Eminem DJ Khaled little
baby post Malone Stephen Curry Gwyneth
Paltrow to name a few all of them
purchasing these pictures of apes for
sometimes hundreds of thousands of
dollars and amongst this sea of high
ticket sales you would hear that this is
all part of something revolutionary it's
the biggest technology that has ever
happened in the history of life outside
of things like fire regardless of how
much you knew about nfts there was one
message that was really clear behind
every story every headline there was an
underlying premise something
is happening and there is a lot of money
to be made
[Applause]
I asked you to explain nfts so popular
talk show host Jimmy Fallon does this
segment on his show with Paris Hilton
where they show off their pictures of
Boris
uh here's my this is my
yours is so cool I love the red heart
sunglasses I love the captain hat it
reminded me of me a little bit dude look
at this they look like they could be
friends they're buddies
[Applause]
uh this was the point in which I started
to wonder okay what is actually
happening and I think a lot of people
started to as well
you start to realize that the purchase
of people's artwork that wasn't done
through 69.3 million dollars in cash
that purchase was made using
cryptocurrencies in fact all the nft
purchases that we were seeing they were
done through cryptocurrency the
mysterious individual who purchased
people's artwork that went by the
pseudonym metakova turns out it's this
guy called Vignesh sundarison who is
already a cryptocurrency entrepreneur
and had a working relationship with
people months prior to the big sale and
whilst there was all this talk about the
Revolutionary potential behind what
we're seeing there was another side of
the story that was being painted by
people who are far more skeptical and
those voices had a clear warning what
you are witnessing is a Mania we've got
this system that is gleefully and
gloriously corrupt a Mania that is being
driven by greed get rich quick by
investing in crypto currency Mass
delusion my Abe is an inner reflection
of myself or as other critics put it it
is a giant and scan that has some of the
largest names Brands Venture Capital
firms backing it knowingly or not nfts
were just a component of a much bigger
machine with a lot of moving pieces and
when you put those pieces together it
creates a machine for one of the
greatest scams in human history and it
all begins here with a mysterious
invention and a failed Revolution
2008
that's where this really begins Apple
shares were just getting hammered this
morning we're down by between three and
four and a half percent generally the
United States is going through a
recession it hasn't seen since the Great
Depression the consumers strangled
they're watching their housing prices go
lower they're watching their 401ks get
diminished you created the mess we're in
and now you're saying sorry amongst the
backdrop of this all a mysterious
individual is working on their own
invention on the 31st of October they
send an email to a cryptography mailing
list the email begins I've been working
on a new electronic cash system that's
fully peer-to-peer with no trusted third
party it was signed by somebody under
the pseudonym Satoshi Nakamoto whoever
this Nakamoto person was they had a
vision the vision was to create a type
of currency that existed digitally that
could be controlled by no government or
single individual that could be used to
transacting globally no matter where you
were or what time it was the name of
this currency and invention
Bitcoin
on January the 3rd 2009 Nakamoto
launches his invention creating the
first ever Bitcoins to exist it was an
attractive pitch you know especially to
people who held anti-state control
sentiments you know we're talking about
anarchists techno anarchists
Libertarians cypherpunks these were
individuals who likely saw the
government the banks the entire
financial institution as just
untrustworthy that they they can't be
allowed to control monetary policy and
it was these factions that became the
first adopters of Bitcoin influencing
its early culture the goal was simple
preach the message of Bitcoin to others
and increase its adoption Bitcoin was
kind of like a religion of its own right
like Satoshi Nakamoto was this
jesus-like figure that would communicate
with his disciples on online forums he
would talk of this Future Vision of the
world you know one where the dollar no
longer existed and all transactions
would be made through Bitcoin the global
currency of the people that was owned by
no Central entity to those early a
adopters of Bitcoin they really felt
like they were on the cusp of something
revolutionary it just so happened that
the more people started buying into the
message the higher Bitcoins value Rose
and the more people were willing to like
put real dollars into buying Bitcoins
Bitcoin is now up to 111 Bitcoin started
drawing attention from places it
probably wasn't expecting or even
wanting the guys in suits you know the
the big money the people who saw Bitcoin
as revolutionary but perhaps more
importantly as an opportunity the
Winklevoss Twins were a perfect example
of that I mean here you have two twins
who have graduated from Harvard they've
won a settlement for 65 million dollars
against Mark Zuckerberg for stealing
their initial idea of Facebook they
found out about Bitcoin on a holiday
trip to Ibiza and they started buying as
much as they could they were stockpiling
the currency it was by around 2013 that
they were rumored to own about one
percent of all Bitcoin in circulation
that I think was a perfect early warning
of what was to come foreign Bitcoin was
doomed from the start that's what a lot
of crypto Skeptics will tell you and I
understand why relying on computer code
and the ideals of tech anarchists
probably isn't the best place to entrust
a reimagining of the financial system
Bitcoin had a fixed supply of 21 million
coins which makes it deflationary by
Nature so if one Bitcoin is worth more
tomorrow than it is today
why would you want to use it to transact
with it's a pretty bad incentive to have
if you're trying to make a Global
Currency but that is already assuming
that Bitcoin had the technical
capabilities to become this worldwide
currency which it didn't I mean Bitcoin
had scaling issues thanks to design
decisions that Nakamoto themselves had
made it could only process seven
transactions per second I mean compared
to other traditional payment networks
like Visa which can process 1700
transactions per second or Mastercard
which handles 5 000 transactions per
second and keeping the Bitcoin Network
running wasted a lot of energy Bitcoin
aimed to be decentralized meaning no
government or single entity had control
over it but in order to do that Nakamoto
employed what is called a proof of work
consensus model all this meant was that
computers on the Bitcoin Network would
be forced to use real world energy in
order to solve algorithmic problems and
whichever computer solved the problem
first would be rewarded with more
Bitcoins it was a process called Mining
and that process is insane mainly
wasteful of energy and what ends up
happening proof of work incentivized
this arms race between computers on the
Bitcoin Network all of them looking to
build more and more powerful computers
to have a better chance of mining
Bitcoin and the more powerful those
computers grew the more real-world
energy they ended up taking despite the
fact that the transactions per second
remain the same most Bitcoin mining done
today is done by huge mining farms in
warehouses Bitcoin for the most part
failed in its objective of trying to
become a Global Currency outside of
illegal use purposes Bitcoin just wasn't
being used to transact with so the
obvious question becomes how how is it
that despite its failings Bitcoin still
survived and is very much present to
this day but that's just the thing the
Bitcoin that we see today is a shell of
its former identity where most of the
purchasing of Bitcoin today happens on
centralized exchanges that have to
comply with the laws of centralized
institutions in the instances where
you've heard about Bitcoin or if you've
ever been encouraged to buy Bitcoin
under what context is that always framed
by 2014 the mysterious Satoshi Nakamoto
effectively vanished from the internet
and hasn't been heard from since what
was left of his invention was no longer
a currency it was something entirely
different
Bernie Madoff this was a guy who was
well respected on Wall Street he ran a
brokerage firm with a wealth management
Branch he had many clients investing
with his firm under the promise of great
Returns on their money until the FBI
arrested him this morning after he told
senior employees yesterday that his
business was a giant Ponzi scheme Madoff
had been running the largest Ponzi
scheme in history for the last 17 years
and potentially longer worth around
64.8 billion dollars he would
essentially put his investors money
inside a bank account and then simply
pay out early investors with the money
that new investors were giving now
Madoff eventually pleaded guilty and he
was in prison up until his death in
2021. that is the essence of Eddie Ponzi
scheme people invest into the scheme
under this promise that they're going to
make a great amount of returns and then
early investors are paid using the money
of new investors and this process is
repeated on and on until eventually you
run out of new recruits to keep
investing money in scheme or eventually
people start trying to cash out and it
just collapses which tends to leave
early investors with profits and the
large majority of others with nothing
but losses
people hearing about Bitcoin would hear
about two things one that it was
revolutionary and two that it was
valuable that if you buy now you could
be rich later if you really really want
to become wealthy in the future I would
suggest you take one freaking dollar buy
some Bitcoin Bitcoin to me it's not just
an investment it's not just a maybe a
get rich quick scheme as a lot of people
put it but I see it as the future of
currency I see it as the future of the
financial system so you realize that
most of the people buying Bitcoin
they're not buying it to use as a
currency they're buying it as an
investment and therein lies the
contradiction because the more people
who used Bitcoin like an investment the
less liable Bitcoin became as a currency
the very thing it's being pitched as
being revolutionary as so you know what
you end up with right Bitcoin is a get
rich quick scheme the promise is you can
get rich for free magical internet money
anyone who buys into the idea of Bitcoin
is doing so to sell it for a higher
price at a future date and the people
that buy it of those people are also
looking to sell it for a higher price at
a future day the only way to make money
from your Bitcoin investment is using
the money of new investors you hear
about people making money in Bitcoin
they only make money because some other
sucker lost more and unlike Bernie
Madoff right who gets all the blame and
dissatisfying jail time at the end of
his story here you have an entity that
isn't owned by anyone or some would
argue isn't a decentralized currency
a decentralized Ponzi scheme now Ponzi
schemes are kept Alive by continuously
finding new recruits and new markets to
tap into so that money is continuously
being poured into the scheme and so you
start to see this similar incentive
develop in the crypto space this
desperate need to find a use case for
this stuff and that use case has to be
revolutionary enough to justify its
Rising value Bitcoin may have been the
first part of this machine
the things we're about to get a whole
lot more interesting
Bitcoin had something going for it the
blockchain system that kept it running
was somewhat unique okay so let's not
complicate things right you can think of
Bitcoin like a digital spreadsheet that
records transactions being used in the
currency it's not a physical coin it's
just data on a database after a certain
number of transactions are made a brand
new spreadsheet is created that links to
the previous one and on and on and on it
goes instead of using real names users
are recognized through what are called
wallet addresses which appear as a
random string of numbers and letters and
all of this is kind of kept together
using computer code cryptography and the
network of miners that are running it
which is where the word cryptocurrency
comes from so what was essentially just
an immutable append-only database was
touted as revolutionary you know
blockchain was no longer just blockchain
it was blockchain technology and it
wasn't long before people started to see
the success and the ideals that Bitcoin
was based off and begin creating their
own cryptocurrencies using this
blockchain system
[Music]
vitalik buterin a teenager who decided
to quit his favorite video game World of
Warcraft after his warlock character had
a damage component removed by the game
developers vitalik says that he cried
himself to sleep that night that was the
day that he realized the horrors the
centralized Services bring it sounds a
bit ridiculous but vitalik would end up
discovering Bitcoin in 2011 and he would
start writing for a Bitcoin magazine it
all appealed to his ideals in 2015
vitalik and several other co-founders
launched the creation of their own
blockchain based invention it was called
ethereum much like Bitcoin ethereum had
its own blockchain and it had its own
native currency which was called ether
there was one important difference
though you see ethereum allowed its
users to actually program applications
on its blockchain put it this way if
Bitcoin was like a spreadsheet then
ethereum was like an Excel spreadsheet
that allowed users to create functions
to perform various different tasks
because it was you know a little more
advanced it was a glimpse of Hope at
finding the Revolutionary use cases in
the cryptocurrency world needed in order
to justify the growing value that was
being pumped into the system so what was
the first thing that people started
using ethereum for
creating more cryptocurrencies and today
we will be creating our own
cryptocurrency in under 10 or maybe even
under 5 minutes rather than needing to
create your own blockchain and network
you could just use ethereum's blockchain
to create your own cryptocurrencies or
crypto assets as people called them
these assets that existed without their
own native blockchain were called tokens
there are now over 1500 cryptocurrencies
it became known as the Ico Mania it was
supposed to be this new way to fund your
business businesses could create their
own token coins release what is called a
white paper which explains what the
project aimed to do and then they could
sell those tokens to the public
otherwise known as an initial coin
offering I see a whole wave of these
token coins were being released some of
them parodies and others were just
blatant scams Bitcoin the Whopper coin
Trump coin Kodak coin insane coin but
here it is so I created dictator coin
Jesus coin was a token coin that was
promising to decentralize Jesus on the
blockchain on its white paper its
creators stated they were in early talks
with churches to provide Miracles
exclusively to Jesus coin owners Ponzi
coin was very much open about the fact
that it was a scam their website
literally said it right there is as much
as a scam as 99 of the icos out there
but it's more transparent about it Ponzi
coin still managed to raise 250 000 it
didn't matter if the idea was good
enough or not or if it even solved the
problems it was claiming to solve all
the mattered was that people believed in
the token enough so that the value would
rise and it would pay off the early
investors who got in at the start there
was one that you invested in that saw
like two thousand percent growth last
month yeah that was damn recording icos
also marked the beginning of an unlikely
friendship between those in the
cryptocurrency space and influencers and
celebrities if token coins were fueled
by hype and detention then celebrities
and influences were the ones that were
running the gas stations famous
professional boxer Floyd Mayweather
along with producer DJ Khaled were paid
one hundred thousand dollars and fifty
thousand dollars respectively to promote
the token coin Centro Tech in 2017.
centratec was a project that was
promising to deliver Financial Services
to the cryptocurrency world the queen
had raised 32 million dollars turns out
they lied about their CEO who wasn't
even a real person that existed they
lied about business deals with
MasterCard and visa and its co-founder
Sam Sharma was eventually sentenced to
eight years in prison icos effectively
became a casino to gamble unregistered
Securities but you have to remember the
hidden incentives no matter how
fraudulent or bizarre everything looks
on the outside in the crypto world you
have to keep clushing a potential use
cases or or anything that will justify
its value constantly rising to new
investors and whilst the Ico Mania of
2017 was continuing a whole new idea was
coming to fruition
so how many of y'all have heard of this
new game that came out recently I don't
know how you how how do we actually
describe what these things are and today
we're talking about crypto kitties
crypto kitties was probably one of the
first nft projects to make it into the
spotlight crypto kitties crypto kitties
the viral blockchain based game that
sparked a global craze or virtual cast
it's a picture of a cat you logged onto
the site you created an account that was
connected to your crypto wallet and
you'd play this game in which you would
collect breed and sell virtual cats for
cryptocurrency the key pitch here though
is that every cat is its own unique
token that exists on the ethereum
blockchain making them what you would
essentially call non-fungible or as
they're often called now a non-fungible
token an nft think of it like a digital
Beanie Babies now if that sounds a
little weird it's because
it is crypto Keys became like its own
Mania it generated three million dollars
within its first week of launch and
accounted for roughly 10 to 13 of all
traffic on ethereum's network and where
was everyone's Focus during that Mania
okay that's two thousand seven hundred
dollars for this little guy why use
these cryptokitties 450 000 for this
ugly mug the same reason you started out
with the cryptocurrency to make guys
this is a potential way to make some
money this insane most users are trying
to breed their cats at the moment not
just because it's kind of cold but also
because they can be very expensive there
are thousands of people playing on the
crypto kitties website once everyone
started rushing to join in on the hike
the economics of the game began to
falter as the supply of crypto kitties
stretched far beyond the demand
eventually leading to a crash in the
price of crypto kitties and a full in
average users because as you continue to
see time and time again almost everyone
was there to make money but what
remained of that Saga was the idea of
non-fungible assets a brand new package
a brand new pitch a new route to find
use cases for cryptocurrencies and
blockchain Technology
this stuff was initially pitched to
digital artist the idea was that you
would make artwork then tokenize that
artwork which just means turning it into
a token that exists on a blockchain like
ethereum if you wanted to know who owned
the artwork all you had to do was just
go and check the blockchain records and
see which wallet was associated with the
artwork in theory you could digitally
verify the ownership of your art sounds
exciting you might think I did too
digital artist Michael winkelmann
otherwise known as people began in
challenge in 2007 where he would create
one piece of artwork every single day
and continue to do so throughout the
years it was known as his everydays
collection but to me the bigger project
is this long-term everydays project
which is a project that I've been
working on you know every single day for
over 12 years it was reportedly around
October of 2020 when people was put in
touch with an anonymous nft artist
called pack and pack informed people
about the world of nfts only a few
months later he would end up auctioning
a piece of artwork that contained a
collage of the first 5000 images of the
everyday series titled everydays the
first 5 000 days
69.3 million dollars was how much it
sold for in The Ether cryptocurrency one
of the largest sales in digital art
history the very sale that sent the
search term nft skyrocketing so now the
question becomes who decided to make
that purchase so you purchased a
collection of 5 000 pieces of digital
art that anyone can easily see online
for 69 million dollars why did you do
that
[Music]
well as they were later revealed to be
Vignesh sundarison a crypto entrepreneur
who had recently co-founded a crypto
investment firm with his business
partner called metapurse only a few
months before this big 69 million dollar
purchase metakovan and his business
partner had already bought another
collection of nfts from people for over
2.2 million dollars they actually wrote
a blog post about their purchase
alluding to the fact that this was only
part of a much bigger project that they
had in mind that will quote flip the art
World status quo on its head and what
was that project that they were talking
about
the B20 token coin they were going to
bundle their purchases of people's nfts
collection and put it in a virtual
Museum where those who purchased the B20
token coin could access and view the
artwork owning the B20 token was
supposed to represent a type of
fractional ownership in the virtual
Museum and the contents inside of it
here's the thing metakovan and his
business partner conveniently owned 59
of the total supply of B20 tokens beeple
was also given two percent of that
Supply people and metakovan already had
a working relationship before the big
everydays 5000 sale when that sale
happened and the media frenzy ensued the
B20 token Rose in value to 23 as more
people began obviously looking into who
metokovan was people have accused that
sale of essentially being a giant
marketing stunt to increase the value of
the B20 token even in their cools
together you can hear people Express
skepticism around the whole thing only
for metakovan and the others to kind of
bring him around other artists I can
almost guarantee will not like this like
they will not like you taking their work
and like
and likes and reselling those pieces I
that I would be very surprised if other
artists did not have a very
strong dislike of that but what I find
the most insane about this Saga was that
the B20 virtual Museum that was supposed
to flip the art World status quo was
nothing impressive the B20 token has
fallen over 99 in value since its
all-time high
despite all of this metakovan cells send
headlines skyrocketing suddenly nfts
were being craded out of internet memes
or anything really that was culturally
relevant to the internet from the
outside all you had to know were that
nfts were revolutionary and there was a
lot of money involved you didn't even
have to know that they were
intrinsically tied to the world of
cryptocurrencies or blockchain a
successful repackaging once the sale of
memes and other one-off nft sales cooled
down it became more popular to start
buying into nft projects these contained
up to thousands of nfts inside of them
usually following a certain theme or
concept what are crypto chunks this
these are the crypto Parts 25 by 25
pixels yeah they're icons of zombies and
uh aliens zombies and yeah they all have
different Mohawks and glasses and beard
types and I mean what is Cool Cats the
coolest nfts on the Block shoot I get a
lazy lions and if they've been thinking
about joining this amazing Community
clone X this project is previously known
as Akira's Nikki vampire it's got pudgy
Penguins on The Chopping Block today
they're selling us something called mini
bits just as it had been with Bitcoin
and token coins the name of the game was
about hyping up a project that you can
sell it for profit later nfts though
were cooler than your average token coin
so they had art behind them you could
show them off by replacing your social
media profile picture with an nft you
purchase more so than ever hype and
attention became an important part of
growing the value of an nft
which brings us to the Apes
one of the most significant projects
created after people's sale was the
board ape Yacht Club otherwise shortened
to just basey founded by the company
Yuga Labs the project featured 10 000
different pictures of apes with this
distinct board expression on their face
the ball rape Yacht Club project had
managed to arrive into the nft space at
just the right time about a month after
people was big sale there were a few
popular people inside of the nft space
already one of which went by the name of
Jimmy McNeil's otherwise known as Jimmy
eth on Twitter who shortly after finding
out about the project announces their
purchase of hundreds of board ape nfts
then another popular figure in the nft
space pranksy who had around 50 000
followers at the time tweets their own
purchase of 250 board eights which later
grows to 1 250. and all the time these
guys are tweeting about their purchases
to their followers it starts to create
this Buzz inside of the crypto space
you've probably seen all over Twitter
this crazy crazy thing with just after
12 hours of its official launch the
Bassy collection sold out giving yoga
Labs an estimated 2.8 million dollars in
Revenue pranksy starts selling some of
his Apes to NBA players who start
tweeting and changing their profile
pictures to those Apes in August the
popular DJ Steve oh he tweets his own
forty thousand dollar purchase of a
board ape to his millions of followers
hashtag eight follow ape began trending
immediately famous digital artist people
tweeting about it and creating an
artwork about it which will continue to
drive up the price of board Apes
me a friend
one of the shadiest parts about
everything that followed were the
Blurred Lines between celebrities and
influencers clearly manipulating a
market to pump up the value of their
nfts and genuine posts simply just
showing off their purchases you had
Justin Bieber in January of this year
posting a picture of a board 8 number
3001 to his 251 million followers a
purchase that was reportedly worth 1.3
million dollars everyone sort of assumes
that the Justin was the one that made
the purchase himself right and he's just
posting it on his Instagram but then
Twitter users started to look into the
records and they find that Justin's
supposed crypto wallet had received 900
ether from another wallet address and
that wallet address was associated with
an individual named jean-pierro de
Alessandro or as many others May
recognize him Justin Bieber's business
partner and Jan Piero owned his own nft
collection called in-betweeners which
Bieber had been promoting on social
media already in those posts no
disclaimer was made suggesting that
Bieber had been paid to promote them I
just got my first nft are you dead what
was it I through moonpay in some of the
announcements from celebrities about
their nft purchases there was this
constant reference to a company called
moonpay thanking them for help with
purchasing their nfts I got an ape too
because I saw you on the show with
people and you said you got a moon pay
turns out moonpay was a company that was
launched in 2019 which according to
their website had One Singular aim to
increase cryptocurrency adoption so that
begs the question what is the
relationship between moonpay and the
supposed celebrities and influences
there helping Buy nfts
advice
three times
aboard a full moon
they want you to not disclose that they
had purchased isn't it a little shady
that you have the CEO of moonpay a guy
called Ivan Soto Wright who is an active
participant in the nft market who is
clearly well connected to the
celebrities using his company service
who has access to Insider information
and likely knows when celebrities May
purchase an nft before they do it and
surprise surprise people started finding
out that right on numerous occasions has
purchased nft projects right before
celebrities end up purchasing them
prominent crypto skeptic and author
David Gerrard had this post on his blog
it was titled cryptographers try to scam
artists again he wrote the nft grift
works like this one tell artists there's
a gusher of free money nfts are the
future if you want
buy into crypto to get the gusher of
free money three they become crypto
Advocates and make excuses for proof of
work and so on 4. a few artists really
are making life-changing money from this
five you probably won't be one of them
it's sold to you as this amazing thing
where art is digitally verified on the
blockchain and that pitch makes you
think that on the blockchain when you
purchase an nft there's literally an
entry that shows your wallet and the
actual image of the nft you purchased
right there you want to know what is
actually the case with most nfts there
is no picture attached to the
transaction instead it's usually a https
or ipfs link containing the stored nft
image so what you're purchasing with
most nfts is just an entry in a database
that contains a link to the image that
anyone else can also access a little
misleading to call that ownership but I
guess at the end of the day that doesn't
matter when just like icos nfts were
just another speculative give Financial
investment to throw your money into and
to do that you had to buy into
cryptocurrencies more money funneled
into the machine
in my experience of looking into crypto
communities and its culture and various
projects there is this game that is
being played some are blatant about it
and others less so but the game is this
everyone is playing a role in promoting
their project calling it revolutionary
saying that this isn't like the others
but ultimately everyone knows that at
some point they're going to sell and
perhaps it is because of the Grateful
nature of the crypto ecosystem where
everyone is incentivized to keep putting
money into the system and to keep
pushing it while simultaneously
dismissing criticism on the surface
everything is supposed to be positive
and optimistic you have catchphrases and
actions that are commonly used in
cryptocurrency communities Hudl
shortfall hold on for dear life which
refers to holding on to your crypto
assets no matter what hodling is seen as
a good thing today we're going to be
talking about the art of the whole
wagami short for we're all going to make
it which is used as both a greeting and
an easy catchphrase to keep morale High
we're all gonna make it and I say this
with passion and confidence
if you leave the market if you give up
you will lose that is the ultimate
failure we're still early is a sentiment
often echoed in crypto communities an
encouraging message for those who are
both new and old in the space letting
them know that they haven't missed out
on the opportunity and further riches
are on the horizon don't abandon hope is
it too late to get into crypto no never
it's never too late it's actually too
early it's extremely early still those
who hold on to their crypto assets even
when there is really good reason to sell
are called Diamond hands Diamond hands
is actually a requirement keep Diamond
handing okay a positive tree that is
encouraged whereas those who do sell are
labeled paper hands a negative trait
which is actively discouraged the worst
part about paper-handed Investors is
that it influences other people to grow
paper on their hands most crypto
communities are encouraged to say good
morning and goodnight to each other
every day shortened to just a GM and GN
kind of like a regular check-in and
check out with members now negativity is
usually handled in the same way since
one group's negativity can actually
devalue a project and affect everyone
else's ability to make money if there's
some bad news about a particular
cryptocurrency project or
cryptocurrencies in general it can be
dismissed as thud abbreviation for fear
uncertainty and doubt we have someone
that again is trying to spread fun I
just couldn't sit idly by him like
find my investment and fought the leader
of my investment or those who criticize
are told you simply don't understand
without any further elaboration or
they're told to have fun staying poor
which is a not so subtle nod to people's
true intentions within the space or
criticism is actually spun into a good
thing for the project these are all very
convenient actions to encourage when
keeping someone engaged and hopeful in a
crypto project is financially beneficial
to everyone else
[Music]
I'm actually struck
by how much the general public really
hates it when someone gets into nfts and
they just have an absolute adverse
reaction I see this across Industries
the nft Mania did something I think it
it grew so big and so in your face from
influencers and celebrities that it
started making people mad
I love being part of this community and
being a voice and sharing my platform
and just getting the word out there what
community what what are you guys talking
about you don't [ __ ] care about this
I hate that they try to put on that they
care about this Ford ape yacht club nfts
which I think are ugly dumb cringe thank
you guys for allowing me to stream about
nft cartoons I hate this stuff it's
getting worse so check this out I got a
board Bunny and not only is a board
bunny but it looks like me look at that
nothing makes people hate you faster
than nft Shilling if you're young and
naive just like my brother and want to
get into nfts you should check out
boarding new board bunny nft project has
now been classified as a scam welcome
David doberger to the long list of
influencers promoting scams further
claiming the team has disappeared with
six million dollars it's great to be a
part of this project I love the designs
inspired by Pokemon it's a Pokemon
knockoff it's just like stealing money
from people who are fans of Pokemon
y'all better not miss this they promised
Pokemon Partnerships uh
all a lie and it ended up raking in 6.3
million dollars for the last six months
I've been working on my own nft project
so the project is called cryptozoom I
believe it's going to change the game
crypto Zoo Logan Paul's newest project
are basically a bunch of stock photos
from Adobe that have been poorly
photoshopped unfungible tokens yes I do
know what they are but I don't
[Music]
really nobody seems to like nfts we
didn't find anybody who actually had
anything positive to say about them
whenever a big celebrity or influencer
would post something related to nfts on
their social media you'd see a whole
slew of people responding with oh no not
you too and this wasn't just limited to
individuals either companies began
getting a lot of flack for even talking
about or dabbling into nfts in 2021
people found out what cryptocurrency
actually was and they hated it is all
get rich quick schemes promoted using
technology as the cover all of it that's
what crypto is and nft is the largest
species I think in June there were 1500
computer scientists and technologists
who wrote to Congress calling for more
responsible regulation of crypto assets
they said that catastrophes and
externalities related to blockchain
Technologies and crypto asset
Investments are the inevitable outcomes
of a technology that is not built for
purpose and will remain forever
unsuitable as a foundation for
large-scale economic activity and so you
start to wonder like okay like what's
gonna happen and I know that it really
shouldn't surprise me
but a whole new packaging had been in
the works and a brand new word was
taking the stage
our mission at moonpay
on board the world to web 3. I have to
admit it's a pretty convincing narrative
the first iteration of the internet web
1.0 was essentially the first version of
the web mostly consisting of web pages
and information there wasn't much you
could actually interact with then came
along Web 2.0 which brought access to
many new features it focused on user
generated content social media and more
forms of participation this version of
the internet became dominated by large
corporations Web 2.0 is our current
modern day version of the internet but
now web 3.0 is coming it kind of just
referred to a bunch of different things
but the idea was that a new version of
the internet is here where your online
activity was going to be making use of
blockchains and tokens to some degree or
another so in theory the now centralized
version of the internet owned by big
Tech would become owned Now by its users
in its initial bubble nfts were seen as
just digital art right which is quite
limiting at the end of the day nfts are
just data on a public database that can
act as a receipt of ownership over
whatever that data contained you know
whether it was a coin or it was a web
link to a digital piece of art the idea
was that if nfts could prove ownership
over something then you could put
anything on the blockchain real estate
titles medical records University
degrees legal records in the case of web
3 you'd have social media sites and
video games all incorporating blockchain
and nfts into their business model it
didn't really matter what it was or how
it would work exactly it just became
this game of insert anything here but on
the blockchain and just like that you've
made it revolutionary you've just
recreated the entire mortgage
infrastructure that already existed it
on the blockchain but that exactly the
blockchain in real estate is going to be
pretty mainstream five to ten years from
now let's see solar grids electric grids
self-driving car grids that will
essentially be machine run and trolled
and administered by blockchain best use
case for blockchain is Healthcare what
can and can't be turned into an nft
ultimately what we're talking about is
the tokenization of everything never
mind if blockchains or tokenization
actually fix the issues that it was
claiming to solve in these industries it
was literally the definition of a
solution in search of a problem and then
I'm lost as to like why the on the
blockchain part matters besides
basically what everyone means is they
mean oh I want a public record of the
transaction okay I mean people suggested
that you could replace legal contracts
with small contracts which are programs
that are built on the blockchain and
that's usually accompanied with the
phrase coder's law this is a smart
contract and this is a legal contract
these two things aren't the same right
you can't have law be enacted by
computer code because law inherently
requires third parties to assess
evidence intentions and a bunch of other
variables that you just can't Outsource
that to computer code especially when
that code is on the blockchain and it
cannot be altered Nicholas Weaver a
researcher and lecturer at UC Berkeley's
department for computer science has this
interview with current affairs and he
brought up what he called Weaver's iron
law of blockchain when somebody says you
can solve x with blockchain they don't
understand X and you can just ignore
them so you start to wonder right who is
behind all of this money that's coming
and pouring into the crypto and web 3
space where is it coming from and why
either I'm not seeing the Revolutionary
potential that all of this has or this
genuinely is a massive Mania and bubble
that is being fueled by greed and
delusion the so-called next version of
the internet that's attracting big money
from Adventure Capital Venture firm
um called Andreessen Horowitz have you
guys heard of it I kept seeing this
venture capital name pop up we've been
in the space for a long time kind of a
big deal running the crypto fund with
more than 7 billion in capital to deploy
Andries and Horowitz otherwise known as
a16z they're one of the largest Venture
Capital firms they have a crypto fund
with around 7.6 billion to be invested
in crypto and web 3 startups and have
been investing in crypto companies
dating back to 2013. if you wanted to
meet the smart money behind all of this
then these guys were the best place to
start they say that crypto is far more
than just a financial Innovation it's
social cultural technological in the
month of October of 2021 a16z led a
funding of 150 million dollars towards
the company that was behind axi Infinity
a16z General partner Ariana Simpson
claimed that this was an example of
where web3 is going to revolutionize the
internet in her own words literally axi
embodies a new generation of games what
this means for the future of games and
really the web as we know it is as big
as your imagination will allow
where do I begin
actually Infinity was what you would
call a play to earn game it was this new
genre of games appearing in the web 3
space which as the name suggests allows
players to make money when they play the
game in the case of axi infinity what
you had was this game where people would
breed collect and fight with these
creatures called axes when battling
inside the game it was possible to earn
this token called SLP which could
actually be traded for real money so
what started happening well people
started playing the game but instead of
focusing on the fun of the game the
focus became on how to earn more SLP how
do we profit from XC Infinity the most
expensive accent I've ever sold was
worth about eight hundred thousand
dollars I've invested 13
232 dollars
is even play axi Infinity you had to
purchase three axi nfts right and as the
value of axi nfts start to rise certain
players wouldn't be able to afford the
buy-in price so guess what started
happening those who had the money to buy
three axes began to lend their creatures
out to players who couldn't afford it
and they were called Scholars how to set
up your own scholarship program as a
manager in axi Infinity I'll be giving
out a scholarship every two weeks so
that's another six scholarships is my
goal Scholars would then play the game
using their rented axes earn SLP and
then give a cut of their earnings to
their managers my team of 12 Scholars
was roughly earning me 1 700 a month 600
from my Scholars with all my current
scholarships working I'm earning about
six thousand dollars a month axi
Infinity a play to earn crypto gaming
Juggernaut that has led people in
countries like Philippines and Venezuela
to make a living these are players from
the Philippines who are making a living
playing accents most of the scholars who
couldn't afford the buy-in price they
were from developing countries right
people who likely saw actually Infinity
not as a game of leisure but as a means
of producing income I am here to apply
scholarships Infinity I want this
scholarship because I want to earn more
I can play 6 to 12 hours a day just for
playing after infinity I will treat this
as a job not just only a game I want to
help my family under expenses and save
up money for my tuition on college so I
want to be a scholar
so that I can meet the needs of my
family what you ended up with was a game
where players are playing in order to
make money people are basically feeding
their entire villagers playing our games
but the only reason that they're making
money is because others are buying into
also make money in the case of things
like actually Infinity there actually
are a bunch of innocent victims right I
mean when you run a pyramid scheme
unfortunately you get a bunch of poor
people in the Philippines who are poor
when they start and they're just hoping
to make some money but then what happens
is they actually lose money the value of
SLP which is the token that people use
to actually make money in the game has
fallen 99 since its peak and its user
base has been in Decline since Times
magazine came out with this article and
it was interviewing this guy called
samerson orias a line cook from the
Philippines who was facing Financial
stress after his mother had a stroke and
electricity and grocery bills were
stacking up Arias jumped into the axi
Infinity game and then exited 14 months
later he described it as boring and
stressful Arias along with other players
of the game told Times magazine that
acts see Infinity reinforce predatory
systems and gave them false hope it's
already dystopian as hell but
people in the developing world that's
not just dark that [ __ ]
again I find myself coming back to the
same question
what is it that VC firms are seeing the
potential in in this crypto space why do
they keep pouring money into it
the overwhelming majority of tokens are
our Securities yeah but they're being
dumped onto retail investors this is
being done explicitly by Venture firms I
won't mention any names who are buying
into companies early getting into tokens
and then those tokens are being listed
on exchanges the public is buying into
them in order to get a financial gain
they have no interest in using those
tokens for any utility VC firms have a
commonly used strategy they invest in a
bunch of startups most of those startups
will fail a few will succeed and with
the ones that succeed a VC needs to
decide on an exit strategy an event that
allows them to liquidate their position
in a company and essentially make money
this is a process that can take years so
there's a another idea that is proposed
by Skeptics that the world of crypto
offers an incentive for VC firms to
invest in a crypto company receive a
percentage of their tokens and then sell
those tokens to retail Traders when it
becomes publicly available all
achievable within months highly
profitable and fairly unregulated with
crypto tokens they can cash out in a few
months and the way that this actually
works is they encourage their fundees to
basically issue unregistered Securities
Anderson Horowitz invested in a bunch of
startups that all issued tokens that all
got dumped on retail including Anderson
Horowitz dumping a lot of them on retail
this is blatant Securities fraud but
they didn't commit the Securities fraud
it was just the companies they invested
in on the surface web3 has this
narrative which is all about taking
money out of the hands of the rich and
the big Tech and giving it back to the
users but a16z is the exact same company
that has funded some of the biggest web
2 companies like Facebook and Twitter
I'm sure that there are many inside of
these firms that you know really believe
in the potential of web 3 or crypto or
blockchains or whatever buzzword you
want to use but it becomes increasingly
harder to see that as anything thing
other than hyper optimism or another
word for it delusion there's this
interview with Mark Andreessen right
who's the co-founder of Andreessen
Horowitz and he's on this podcast
episode with an economist and blogger
called Tyler Cohen and he proposes the
idea for podcasts to make use of web3 a
well-known podcast host how does that
person get paid in a better way through
web 3.0 make that more concrete for us
now Mark Andreessen is someone that by
all accounts should have a good answer
to this question but instead yeah I mean
I mean they can pick their business
model I mean they can pick their
business model they can decide you as a
super based business model you know
micro transactions they can pick you
know they can pick whatever model they
want
um you know they can also have indirect
you know there's this old this whole new
rise of this kind of the the
non-fungible token you know when pressed
to give an actual use case what you get
is an answer with all the right
buzzwords and phrases but little actual
substance I compare it to the internet
like in all seriousness I compare it to
the internet which is the internet
basically 93 or so yeah it's like 93 94.
this is the only the only time I've ever
said this is like the internet is is
this a16z uses the same narrative that a
lot of crypto enthusiasts will also use
you may hate it you may think it's a fad
but crypto and web 3.0 are just like the
internet even I made this comparison
when I looked at the entire space in a
more favorable light now though
I just think it's another form of smoke
and mirrors it is the biggest technology
shift since the internet the blockchain
the consumer blockchain's the biggest
new thing since the internet itself
Bitcoin began in 2009 arguably
blockchain technology and the
foundations for it began even earlier
than that it's been 13 years since this
story began with Bitcoin 13 years to
find a solid use case or at least one
that justifies the hype and is already
better than an existing system crypto
and web 3 is really great at one bang
which is trading and speculation and
there is absolutely no democratization
of anything the centralization of
exchanges centralization of miners
centralization of crypto wild is the
most concentrated amount of centralized
wealth in the history of humanity worse
than disease
it's all [ __ ] 13 years after 1983
which is considered to be the birth of
the internet we were already seeing very
clear-cut use cases even in those early
days people could weather reports they
could check the news they could send
emails and many other uses that we still
use to this day I sent a message to my
doctor asking for a repeat prescription
and he said he's left the prescription
for me in the chemist by even making the
comparison to one of the biggest
Revolutions in information and
communication is already assuming that
cryptocurrencies are revolutionary and
they're bound to find mass adoption at
some point when that is the very future
we're putting into question
[Music]
one recent post that I remember on the
Bitcoin subreddit was titled does anyone
else feel like Bitcoin is their literal
last ditch effort to become wealthy in
their lifetime I don't imagine that this
is the only person in the crypto space
that is thinking that way the crypto
machine has continued running new
packaging of ideas more money funneled
into the system and a constant search to
find a use case that justifies the hype
and the claims of revolutionary
technology if the critics are right then
what we're looking at is a ticking Time
Bomb if the critics are right then this
is a scheme that will leave tons of
regular individuals left holding their
bags wondering how this managed to
happen it already has a scheme that
managed to infiltrate the realm of media
and entertainment that managed to make
use of social media's ability to spread
this fear of missing out they
capitalized on Greed and a get rich
quick mentality if the critics are right
then I suppose there's only one question
that remains
at what point does the ticking Time Bomb
go off
[Music]